2015 on the drive over heroes like I
can't believe we're back here again
insane this year's not going to be as
crazy controlling to be within two days
and then we have to head back so yeah
let's get let's get cute
oh they are cute oh they're nice the IJ
that's me and totally caught they're
really adore they're really cute I'm in
love
yes I like that cake and it's great oh
they're so cute
lego dimensions around we're going to be
doing a signing with Nathan Sawaya today
at 4 o'clock
he's the brilliant artist that's been
creating all of these lego vignettes and
hopefully you guys get a chance to take
a look at I can't believe it
I am so upset I can't believe it I
forgot mine is in the 30s like I don't
even know how I need to go home I'm
driving two hours home
me I'm leaving I'm leaving I can see
here world's greatest legal
master-builders unites yes hello
that's me remember when Libby's voted
Legos with the children I do remember oh
my gosh you better get a picture of me
in here please please Jenna please
August 1st so mini you for your birthday
well I'd like maybe something else too
okay
hi we're here at the MTV fandom Awards
and every day to you a comic-con and
right now we're going to go to the black
ops 30 locked rooms on the experience I
have no idea what to expect but the
costumes on these zombie
Wow
oh my goodness this looks awesome
I'm terrified oh my god
it's gonna be us you have to do it
it looks really cool
I think they either
none of this rounds who holds the time
of your salvation but the clock is
ticking the homeless
remember you should have your blue is
use that color to open what do you need
to be more into soon please gather
closely listen carefully run
somehow we ended up on it
the art of the breath we did right here
it brings our Kovac on to festivities to
close I'm not even sure what I filmed
don't even know did I feel very there
hmm okay but I wanted to end my little
video here and show you guys with link
you air conditioning for coming on and
just really turn it up off so to show
you at Cody and Jorden brought for me
and Jenna this is absolutely amazing so
you guys have seen all of the crazy
little adventures that my Lego mini
figure has been on well she's got an
updated hoodie and Jenna look at it it's
so cute I can't even believe it I love
them so much time to drive home I'm
tired I want to sleep until Tuesday see
you later